[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock on christmas eve a cautious
christmas message from the prime
minister ahead of family time but a hint
of optimism from one top doctor around
the latest omicron data we'll talk to
the boss of nhs providers this morning
to find out what's happening in our
hospitals and will we all need to get a
fourth jab
it's christmasy
the prime minister says omicron is
surging and warns us to protect our
elderly relatives this christmas but top
doctor is cautiously optimistic with
risk of hospitalizations low
when omicron is surging where we all
know we must together try to stop the
spread of this new variant we must test
ourselves and take extra care when
meeting elderly or vulnerable relatives
it's very early days only a small number
of individuals about 100 were admitted
to hospital with omicron in this period
but nonetheless it is
first signs of cautious optimism we can
have for a while
carrying favor with the health secretary
we visit the bradford restaurant that's
got vindaloo and vaccines on the menu
a personal touch a new picture of the
queen she prepares for her first
christmas message since the death of her
husband
and i'm here at windsor castle where the
queen will spend christmas with prince
charles and camilla
guilty
the former u.s police officer who said
she mistakenly fired her gun instead of
a taser killing 20-year-old motorist
dianne taywright
head of glen county state of minnesota
find the defendant guilty
fresh diplomatic boycott as japan says
it won't send government officials to
the beijing winter olympics and a
chinese city locks down because of covet
19.
dynamite decision the car owner who
decided to blow up his vehicle with
dynamite as it was too pricey to repair
driving
[Music]
and as we wait to find out what's made
the festive number one later on today
we'll talk to one singer who's been
driving all his songs home for christmas
and we'll find out how to keep your pets
safe this christmas with an animal
behaviorist at half past
[Music]
morning everybody the prime minister has
released his christmas message saying
omicron is surging and has urged people
to get tested and be careful when
visiting elderly and vulnerable
relatives but one top doctor at the uk
health security agency says she is
cautiously optimistic about the latest
omicron data and the lower risk of
hospitalization
analysis by the uk security health
agency shows that people with omicron
are 30 to 45 less likely to go to a a
and e than with the delta variant
they're also between 50 and 70 less
likely to be admitted to hospital
but the study also found that the effect
of the booster vaccine against the
variant wanes after 10 weeks
the christmas message from the prime
minister still has a note of caution as
sadia chaudhary reports
just a day until christmas and the prime
minister and the leader of the
opposition want the focus to be on
festivities and praising people for
helping each other out
we know that things remain difficult
but
for millions of families up and down the
country i hope and believe that this
christmas is and will be
significantly better than the last and
though the time for buying presents is
theoretically running out
there is still a wonderful thing you can
give
your family and the whole country
and that is
to get that jab in the darkest of times
christian values of kindness of
compassion and hope have shone through
communities have come together to help
one another
key workers have saved countless lives
with no mention of new restrictions
there are questions about the way
forward
for me nothing's changed because it's
just at home with families compared to
sort of scotland and wales that have
tightened things up a bit i think we
should have done a little bit more
sooner i think the main thing is you
know the cases are going up but their
death rates are still quite low
obviously one death is one death too
many but they are staying low nothing's
changed
what do you think under control as the
country prepares to stop for a few days
the nhs is pressing on
festivities will continue and so will
the vaccine program with jabs being
administered on christmas and boxing day
it comes as coveted cases hit a record
high
again latest data shows the uk recorded
119
789
new coveted cases in the latest 24-hour
period that's the highest daily figure
since the start of the pandemic
but there is some optimism from new
research
it shows that
people with omicron have a reduced risk
of hospitalization compared to delta
now it's very early days only a small
number of individuals about 100 were
admitted to hospital with omicron in
this period
but nonetheless it is uh first signs of
cautious optimism we can have for a
while for that optimism to last
infections will need to be curbed these
scenes from last night of an unusually
quiet soho suggest that could be a
possibility sadia chaudhary sky news in
london
okay so let's look at the latest kobe
data for you should we as you heard
earlier 119
789 new cases of covet 19 were reported
for the latest 24 hour period another
single day record
147 more people have died sadly taking
the number of people who have died
within 28 days of a positive coveted
test to 147
7720
more than 39 000 people have received
their first dose of the vaccine 53 000
their second that means that more than
47 million people have now received two
doses
840 000 boosters were given meaning more
oh
nearly 31 in fact 31.7 million people
have now had their job
uh their jab i should say or their
booster
okay let's speak to oksana pizzick
leader of the outbreak educational
program in infectious diseases at ucl
hello to you thanks for joining us on
the programme this morning
from reading this morning's newspapers
there does seem some cautious optimism
around ahead of christmas
well i certainly think this is news that
many people have been hoping for
uh however cautious optimism is the
right word many of the these
epidemiological studies are predictors
because it's only using a very small
number of people who have been
hospitalized so far to make these
predictions from so looking at a hundred
people is very different than a
population-wide effect um so that's one
thing the second thing is of course
we have now record-breaking cases of
covid so that's also going to mean that
when we have christmas tomorrow um lots
of intergenerational mixing at hand
that could also
change the uh
trajectory as we go into the new year
but we have had increasing numbers i
mean yesterday i think was the highest
number ever since we were aware of the
pandemic
but the number of people in hospital
with omicron is still relatively low
isn't it
absolutely we know that there is a lag
effect so when we're going to have peak
mixing today tomorrow over the holidays
as well uh we can see that
there will be about a two week delay
before we start to see those hospital
numbers creep up uh but i think the nhs
is really bracing itself for that and
it's not just about number of
hospitalizations it's also disruption
around that uh in the in the nhs as well
we see one in 10 health workers have
also become sick with covid or are off
at the moment which adds additional
pressure to the system uh so certainly
in the next coming weeks it's uh this
cautious optimism doesn't mean we
shouldn't drop our guard getting boosted
is one of the most important things
people can do and i think that
we've already heard it's the best
christmas gift you can give
[Music]
when we look back
at the
vaccines that people were given in the
uk does look as though astrazeneca
perhaps not as effective as some of the
other vaccines
certainly and that's why we see that the
booster jab is very likely to be an mrna
vaccine so either pfizer or moderna to
help top up that layer of protection
unfortunately there is already even some
waning with these boosters however uh
it's important to get
during a winter season like this
to get that maximum protection
but i think going forward what this
indicates is that we may have a new
generation of vaccines that
pharmaceutical companies are already
working on that are variant specific
particularly because with omicron we see
there have been um so many mutations
that just make it so much more adept at
entering the cells within the body so
while we have uh that issue at hand we
also need to think about making sure the
rest of the world uh is also vaccinated
so that we
really stop this whole cycle of new
variants emerging
so to that end that puts us in a
difficult position here in the united
kingdom doesn't it because people like
me that had their booster more than 10
weeks ago that means that my immunity is
now waning
against any new variants of um omicron
or of um covert 19 but also have to
think about friends and colleagues in
south africa and other countries that
have not yet had their first vaccine
absolutely and in terms of uh
knowing that your vaccine effectiveness
wanes over time that that shouldn't
worry people too much in the sense that
there's also b and t cell activity that
helps to um keep immune response up
but it does mean that we may need to
look towards a different solution going
forward we see that israel's solution
has been to um
roll out a fourth job that's not
necessarily the only way to go uh but
globally it's up to leaders and for the
public to put pressure on leaders to say
you know we want out of this pandemic
faster
and we think that that's a really
important issue for ensuring that health
workers uh who are the highest risk
currently right now in africa only one
in four healthcare workers who are on
the front line have even their uh two
jabs let alone a booster so really a
global issue but we seem to find that
lesson really hard to learn elsewhere
if not a fourth job then what
again i'm thinking we're looking at
something very similar to just a yearly
dose so this could be the one year where
we're looking at potentially having uh
top-up doses uh but after that i think
we'll be looking at something just like
the flu jab uh where they adapt it based
on the strain that's circulating uh
potentially a multivalent
vaccine and there are companies that are
working uh on vaccines that can wreck
that are effective across multiple
variants uh so that's really exciting
work that's happening and i think we're
not too far away from it okay good to
talk to you thanks for your expertise
merry christmas merry christmas
take care thank you
now charities and aid agencies say the
row light of the covid booster jab has
highlighted the level of vaccine
inequality across the globe
the uk us and eu have received more
doses of covid19 vaccines in the
six-week run-up to christmas than
countries across africa have received
all year just talking about that weren't
we between the 11th of november to the
21st of december
513 million doses of covid19 vaccine
were given to the uk us and to eu
that's 13 million more than the 500
million doses given to countries across
africa throughout the entire year
just 8.6 of people across the continent
have been fully vaccinated to date and
with estimates suggesting it could take
until april of 2023
for everyone to receive their first dose
at the current rate of delivery by
vaccine manufacturers
if we don't vaccinate people everywhere
in the world variants like omicron are
going to arise in low vaccinated parts
of the world and they're going to come
back and bite us and that we've been
warning about this for months now um i'm
very sad to say that it's that it's come
true
well the queen's christmas day message
is expected to be a particularly
personal one this year as she prepares
to spend her first festive period since
the death of prince philip at windsor
the queen will spend christmas at
windsor which is where we have now sent
emma this morning a little bit easier
than trotting up to sandringham for some
of us um hello to you emma very good
morning um bittersweet because her son
will be with her but sadly her husband
of 70 odd years not so
yes i mean immensely sad year for the
queen
the loss of her husband in april uh at
the age of 99 after more than 73 years
of marriage and the photograph which has
been released was taken here at windsor
castle in the white drawing room
as her christmas message was being
recorded which will be broadcast
tomorrow at 3 p.m as is traditional on
christmas day and in that photograph she
is wearing a chrysanthemum brooch a
particularly
important brooch to her it's one that
she wore on her honeymoon honeymoon a
photograph that was taken with the duke
of edinburgh in
1947 and again that photo recreated in
2007 for their diamond wedding
anniversary and it's that photograph
which is in a frame on the desk in this
latest image which has been
released for us now in advance of
christmas
and the message that we hear about is
going we never get any detail but we're
told uh to expect it to be particularly
personal because of reminiscences about
the loss of her husband
this year and she will be joined here at
windsor castle with her son prince
charles and his wife the duchess of
cornwall okay emma thanks that scene
behind you there emma looks like the
opening scene of a jack the ripper uh
movie or something it's really spooky
there's a certain mistiness here
we'll see you when it's light thanks a
lot still to come on the program before
you will find out how to keep your pets
safe this christmas with an animal
behaviorist
will it snow
on christmas day what are the chances of
a white christmas 7 40 speaking to a
meteorologist from the met office to
find out
meantime a white police officer who said
she confused her handgun for a taser has
been convicted of manslaughter in the
death of a 20 year old black motorist
dante wright in a case which caused
civil rights protests right across the
u.s the judge regina chu read the
verdict to mrs potter
the jury on the charge of manslaughter
in the first degree while committing a
misdemeanor
on or about
april 11 2021
in hennepin county state of minnesota
find the defendant guilty we the jury on
the charge of manslaughter in the second
degree
culpable negligence on or about
april 11 20 21
in hennepin county state of minnesota
find the defendant guilty
well the killing of mr wright provoked
angry protests in minneapolis by black
lives matter supporters who highlighted
the number of cases in which white
police officers have killed black
suspects outside court there were
celebrations when the jury's decision
was read out and mr wright's family said
they were happy with the verdict
all right everybody we've been fighting
for a long time it's been a long nine
months yes we can't speak too much about
everything but we're happy with the
verdict we're happy with the guilty
guilty
and we're not doing this for nobody but
for my mom and my pops
in order to use japan which hosted the
last olympics will not be sending a
government delegation to next year's
winter olympics in china joining other
countries which have refused to send
ministers because of human rights issues
let's speak to our asian correspondent
tom cheshire who is standing by for us
in beijing it's a growing list tom
morning yes it is it was the u.s who
kicked this all off announcing they
wouldn't uh be sending any officials to
the olympics the uk of course joined
them canada australia but not every
country has gone the same way france
which will host the next summer olympics
in paris said it will send a delegation
for japan in a bit of a tricky situation
really has to walk the line here the u.s
is obviously an ally but china is a very
big economic partner it's right on its
doorstep and also china was helpful to
japan during the summer olympics in
tokyo they supported those going ahead
despite covert so what japan has done
here i think is a sort of half in half
out diplomatic boycott it didn't use the
terminology diplomatic boycott but it
won't be sending government ministers on
the other hand it is going to send some
dignitaries from its olympic committees
so i think this is one of the moves that
probably won't anger china quite as much
as we've seen from other countries
especially the u.s
and the uk uh the five eyes intelligence
sharing alliance all not sending
government officials i think china also
has its own worries right now in terms
of covid in the country um in the last
few days xi'an which is the home of the
famous terracotta warriors city of 13
million people has been put into
lockdown a very strict lock down the
strictest since we saw in wuhan in the
early days of the pandemic households
they're only allowed to send one person
out every two days to buy essential
supplies the whole city is being tested
these are very severe restrictive
measures you might be wondering how many
cases they've got in xi'an especially
when we're talking earlier in the
program about more than a hundred
thousand cases yesterday in the uk where
xi'an yesterday recorded 52 cases just
52 cases and as a result they have
locked the entire city down with no end
to that lockdown in sight that's how
seriously china is taking kovit ahead of
the olympics and still pursuing that
zero coveted strategy
okay tom
thanks new figures suggest that on
average 80 officers are assaulted every
day in the uk data gathered by the pa
news agency has shown there were more
than 7 000 assaults against police
officers constables and volunteers in
just three months
in 2021 the police federation of england
and wales says the figures should
concern everybody
we've seen an increase in assaults
against police officers where
offenders are weaponizing covert
in spitting at them or telling them that
they've got other infectious diseases
and we've also seen the level of
violence that's being offered to police
officers increase
significantly only this week
we've had an officer from from
nottingham who had scalding water thrown
over him
rainer has more than doubled its annual
loss forecast over omicron the airline
expects a loss of up to 450 million
euros in the year to the end of march
and has cut the expected number of
passengers by a third for january it's
been blamed on the french and german ban
of uk arrivals and suspension of flights
to and from morocco
one man in finland has found an
interesting way to dispose of his tesla
vehicle
he encountered problems with his car
and then uh when he basically uh went to
have it repaired he was told it would
cost up to 16 000 pounds that's what he
did
instead he took it to um a quarry and
then he decided that he would have it
blown up by dynamite there they also had
a a poke tesla ceo elon moss by making
him the stuntman
in the driver's seat
they don't use that in their adverts
now according to the daily mail the
queen will pay tribute to her late
husband prince philip in her christmas
broadcast
the mirror also leads with her majesty's
speech and the headline always by her
side
the eye ties together to the news that
the omicron variant of covet appears to
be milder than its predecessors with the
government's announcement that there
won't be any further decisions about
restrictions in england until after
christmas
the times says millions of people may
need a fourth covey jab because
protection from a booster starts to wane
after as little as 10 weeks
vaccines and vindaloos will be on the
menu in bradford at a curry house it's
hosting a walk in coronavirus jab clinic
in a first of its kind trial by the nhs
my lahore a british asian restaurant in
bradford will offer first second and
booster inoculations we sent fraser
along to find out more
this indian restaurant in bradford has
cooked up a way of helping out with the
push to get everyone boosted
so along with your papadoms and nuns you
can also ask for a side order of covid
19 vaccine whether you're staff or a
diner yeah i think it's a great idea
because you can hang out with your
friends have something to eat and get a
job and go on
the restaurant has previously partnered
with the nhs to vaccinate their staff
and to host q a sessions for anyone with
concerns about the vaccinations
a lot of our team members wanted to
do the waxing anyway but they just don't
have the time so we thought we'd create
a platform for customers and team
members where they can come and if
somebody wants to take the job
and it's just because of convenience
they can take it and same with the team
members if they if they want to take it
while it's at work
they can do so in the seven days up to
monday there were over two thousand
positive test results in bradford an
increase of 33 percent on the week
before but vaccination levels are
comparatively low in the area around the
restaurant less than 50 percent of over
12s have had their first dose compared
to almost 90 percent nationally and only
39
have had a second dose across the rest
of the uk that total is over 80 percent
we appreciate there are that some people
are cautious
and it is our job and we are spending a
lot of time to encourage as many people
as we can
to come forward and have the vaccination
so we've created a lot of accesses such
as this
walk-in access clinics throughout the
district to encourage people to come
forward and where they feel comfortable
to have that vaccine
the restaurant is one of dozens of
pop-up and walk-in clinics around the
country which the nhs hopes will make it
easier for people to get vaccinated even
those who feel they already have a lot
on their plate over christmas
fraser moored sky news bradford
time for some sights and sounds from
around the world now we start with some
festive cheer from italy how's this the
true christmas spirit
absailing santas have delivered
christmas gifts to children at a
hospital
in rome members of the italian alpine
rescue
as you can see managed to rappel down
the pediatric ward at the umberto uh
hospital much the joy of uh young and
old inside after completing three
abseils from a chimney and from the roof
of the pediatric ward the santas went
inside the hospital to deliver presents
to the children
less than two hours to go before santa
sets off on his annual trip delivering
billions of presents to children right
around the world
at the u.s aerospace defense command
norad has their virtual santa tracker
ready to give us updates on santa's
every move so you'll know exactly when
he's flying over your home kids uh he's
due to set off at nine o'clock
london time so we'll obviously bring
that to you live just as soon as he sets
off he's doing the last bit of packing
on the sleigh the reindeers are just
having their carrots and they'll be
ready to go very soon don't miss it now
look at some of the best pictures making
the morning papers for you today it's
santa claus the daily mail has this
picture of a 60-foot father christmas
drawing in the sand made by a former gp
on beadle bay in
northumberland that's pretty impressive
isn't it um the sun
is
manic monday which is about the final
few business days when certain people
rush to get their christmas shopping in
uh including those guys on motorbikes
the guardian has this picture of the
grinch and an assistant entertaining
youngsters outside hamley's toy shop
on regents street it's always scary the
grinch isn't he and all the jingle
babies the mirror is showing some cute
pictures of newborns in their first
festive photo
shoot just look how cute they look yeah
but we can go one better than that ryan
and rachel sent us this photo of their
adorable newborn
there he is how cute
is he
uh if you've got pictures you'd like to
show us if you're newborn in their santa
outfits or whatever you can tweet me
directly if you would like to at k
burley that's gorgeous isn't it
beautiful little baby are born on the
9th of december still to come we have
the sport with hannah
[Music]
ah now are we going to have a white
christmas we've got the met office with
us very shortly but here's a little
teaser
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
okay this is the way it's looking uh so
far this friday morning watch out for
that band of rain heading our way i
believe it's going to be pretty miz
today and tomorrow will we see snow on
christmas morning though we'll have more
on that as i said coming up with the met
office very shortly
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now sticking with pets let's show you
some pictures from ireland this morning
staff at a shelter in dublin have
captured the reaction of rescue dogs as
they're let loose on a room full of new
toys for christmas how lovely the toys
were donated by supporters of the dog's
trust workers laid them out on the floor
of the training barn at the center
before letting the dogs in one by one to
choose a favorite toy to keep
and take back to their kennel
it's squeaking isn't it so he's not sure
about that one but he finally decides
that that is the one for him he wants
more than one but nope just we've got to
share
now for many this will be the first
christmas with a new pet with many
getting a dog or cat during lockdown the
holidays can be filled with hidden
dangers for pets though so let's find
out what you need to look out for to
avoid a trip to the vets joining us now
is claire haynes animal behaviorist at
the blue cross pets charity hi thanks
for joining us who's that with you this
is eric
hello tell me about eric so eric is
about 11 years old and he's a crossbreed
so he's very big but he's got short
little legs and he was a rescue as well
so he he was a stray originally
lovely now i'm guessing you don't give
him mince pies do you no we definitely
don't
tell us why
so there's a lot of foods and drinks
that we indulge in over the festive
period that are actually toxic to our
pets so one example being the raisins
and currants and sultanas that are in
things like mince pies and christmas
puddings so it can actually make them
really unwell
yeah claire i i remember once having
friends around for christmas there were
loads of us we had to get the emergency
chairs out the shed and we we'd eaten so
much food that we didn't want the
christmas cake so we put it up high and
then we were going to come back to it
after we'd watched strictly or something
and as we came back in the labrador of
my friend had literally finished the
last mouthful of the whole christmas
cake he was as sick as a dog he will
forgive the pun for several days later
but that could have killed him couldn't
it
yeah and absolutely and a lot of the
time that we see animals ingesting food
over christmas it's just that it's an
accident it might not be that we've
given it to them deliberately but
actually we've put it on the side we're
maybe going to clear the plates later or
take food off the table and later on and
yeah we've got an opportunist in the
house that might take advantage of it
but absolutely in worst case scenarios
it can be fatal especially labradors and
they can jump higher than i thought they
could as well that's a lesson learned
for me i'm glad to pass that on but not
just food
got to watch out for the tinsel
yeah so a lot of our decorations as well
so
across our animal hospitals each year we
often end up treating pets who've uh
consumed tinsel potpourri you know
eating bits of baubles and bits of the
tree and that sort of thing so it might
even be what you've put out to make the
house look nice that you don't think
your pets will be as interested in but
the novelty and you know the excitement
uh mean that they might take that
opportunity yeah one of the other issues
i've had in the past is uh real trees
and dogs inside
we know what happens there don't we
it can be a bit calamitous can't it with
pets
pet some real trees
yeah especially if you've got lights on
the trees as well you need to be really
really careful um with that ruins
everybody's presence ruins the trees etc
etc so what do we need to do when it
comes to having lots of people around as
well because some dogs especially if
they've been in shelters are not used to
having so many humans around you need to
be careful not to leave them with the
babies and that sort of thing
absolutely and like you mentioned at the
beginning there's millions more pets in
uk homes than there were at the
beginning of the pandemic so for a lot
of animals it's their first christmas or
certainly after last christmas it's
their first one when people can come
around and they'll watch the celebration
so taking steps like you try to with the
cake of whether it's food keeping that
well out of the way keeping your pets
supervised and always making sure
they've got somewhere quiet to go to so
as you can see like eric he likes a good
sleep so making sure that if there is a
lot of noise and hubbubs they've got
somewhere they can go to where they
won't be disturbed i hope you have a
wonderful christmas thanks for
highlighting that for us claire thanks a
lot merry christmas thank you kay merry
christmas
meantime the queen's christmas day
message is expected to be a particularly
personal one this year she loves dogs
doesn't she as well she prepares to
spend her first festive period since the
death of prince philip in windsor
joining us now royal biographer angela
levin hi angela always great to see you
thank you the dogs will offer a great
comfort weren't they at christmas time
oh yes i mean people who are dog lovers
um feel that they're almost like human
or maybe that's me as a particular
person who doesn't have pets but i think
that the warmth and the recognition that
dogs can sense how you're feeling and
and look after you a bit is is very
rewarding
uh indeed so now she's got charles
wither and camilla hasn't she uh on
christmas day that will offer a great
deal of comfort but um the princess
royal not there
no because her husband's been found
positive for kovid so she has to keep
well away i think it's wonderful that
prince charles and the duchess of
cornwall are coming because if you look
back you know the queen would have
nothing to do with her she didn't think
she was right for
her son and she just avoided going
anywhere where she thought she was and
now they're really close i mean they've
got a lot in common like horses and
indeed dogs but i think it's a real
turnaround when she's seen
the dirtiest for who she is how hard
she's working what a positive effect
she's had on prince charles he's happy
he's more relaxed
and he's got somebody who's very loyal
and stable by his side and i think that
she's now
really recognized that in the fact that
she would want them to spend such an
important day
with her um
it just shows you i mean the duchess has
a belief that if you wait long enough
things can turn round and i think this
is one example
of that
she's waiting a long time it has to be
said
a long time thing i mean that is really
a great love story isn't it that if you
wait 35 years then your mother-in-law
will invite you for christmas now that's
just
but um you know i think it is uh
that's too lovely that they just waited
for each other and they wouldn't
go
whatever happened tell me about her
message um angela because we have seen
pictures of people will see the pictures
on the front pages of the papers um
today and she is wearing the brooch i
think that philip bought her many many
years ago
no that brooch was given to her by her
father
but um it matched her eyes the the
stone matched her eyes but she wore it
on her honeymoon with prince philip and
then last year when they celebrated
of marriage
and i think it's very interesting that
she's chosen a bright very bright
christmasy red
dress
to wear because although we hear that
it's going to be very personal and she's
going to talk about her late husband she
wants to show that she's still strong
and she's there and this is a
day which we must celebrate um
and it's a very important religious day
for her and i think in the photograph
she looks
a little strained
she does she doesn't i thought that yeah
but
um determined to go on
and what about the fact that she's at
windsor rather than standing
well i think that's sensible isn't it i
mean there was due to be 50 members of
the family there which is an enormous
number and with small children and
teenagers and it's quite difficult
because you can catch covid without them
having any symptoms or indeed not even
knowing they've got it um so i think
that's wise and to have a quiet
christmas with
intimate members of the family
and then i think she might go up to
sandringham later
um and enjoy the countryside there she
doesn't usually come back until the
sixth of february um
and so
uh i think she might well do that but
okay have a hullaballoo um as i think i
might adopt that as well actually angela
i think i might go for that see what the
boss says um last day tomorrow until the
6th of feb let's see it's good to talk
to you angela thank you so much merry
christmas thank you for joining us you
bye-bye thanks a lot bye-bye um we've
been trying to be a little bit more
upbeat for you this morning this
christmas eve we've seen beautiful
babies in their christmas outfits uh
we've seen um santa absailing um down
the outside of a pediatric unit in rome
we've also seen the fact that santa is
about to start delivering presents from
nine o'clock this morning we'll bring
you the very latest on that and now
we've got a bit of this experts have
hailed the birth of a rare baby white
rhino at a uk zoo as a little miracle
there he is the southern white rhino
calf was born at africa alive near
lowestoft in suffolk last saturday the
18th of december the species was
previously hunted
to almost extinction but the success of
conservation has seen numbers grow to
around
18 000 although we were talking um to an
expert earlier in the week that was
telling us that poaching in africa is on
the rise again particularly because of
the pandemic uh but that's a little bit
of a ray of sunshine not sure what that
calf is called um but uh she he she
looks uh pretty healthy mum watching on
you wouldn't argue with her would you no
you would not coming up we'll be looking
through the newspapers for you
[Music]
time for the papers the christmas eve
papers joining us journalist and author
yazmin alibi brown and broadcaster pete
price hello to you both good morning hi
hi hi how are you right behind me
merry christmas merry christmas
um let's start with you yasmine should
we talk to me about the front page of
the times newspaper
well this is this is quite um an
important story they're talking about
some people having to have the fourth
jab
um and we know that there are some
people with who whose immune systems
have been compromised by medication or
other
illnesses they have but this story also
talks about the fact that the booster in
any case
according to some new research only
really works for the first three months
and and its effectiveness really fades
after that which i i did not know
um i i can't remember i had my booster
quite a long time ago
so
does this mean we're going to keep
having to take jabs with with corona
until it finally
kind of becomes you know manageable i
don't know it is an important story
it is i actually put those uh questions
that you've just asked um journalists
that you are um to um an epidemiologist
earlier and they were saying that
we it does wane after 10 weeks but there
are all sorts of t cells and other
things that build up as well so we don't
have to worry too much about it but she
did think that we would find ourselves
in a position well a bit like the flu
vaccine we'd have to have it once a year
as opposed to once every 10 weeks which
is good news because being a knee needle
phobe i don't want to have a a jab every
10 weeks if i can possibly help it
lighten the mood for us but if you would
please and talk to us about more common
wise
i will indeed
as it's christmas hey look at that
fantastic
the thing is they've found gary eric's
son has found a new
uh an old version of more common wise a
show that's never been seen it's been in
black and white they've colored it up
and it's going out christmas day so
we've got the queen speech and we've now
got more common wise a brand new episode
which i think is wonderful and i can't
believe i'm actually working with kate
burley this is the best christmas
present ever for me you know what not
everybody says that but thank you very
much
i appreciate it and uh yes i mean we can
sit down with the queen's speech um
after uh having had our turkey and
watching morgan wise with a glass of
champagne
well this is very this is the ft story
um
that
investors are making a fortune
um
by you know
investing in champagne the top range and
i mean the the
prices are extraordinary you can get 12
bottles of something called
salon 2002
for a mere ten thousand pounds it's sort
of champagne capitalism
that's unbelievable
do you have a glass of champagne with
your christmas lunch jasmine or not
bother oh yes i do i do i do have a
couple of glasses but i'm not a big
drinker i do like fizz
[Music]
but that's about it i also i'm very
old-fashioned i love sherry nobody
drinks sherry anymore
no gives you a thick head though doesn't
it sherry
yeah but i a little bit you see it's
this sweet little drink i used to always
love it
yeah pete what do you i've always worked
christmas day for donkey's years i'm
doing it again um tomorrow morning and
my little boy is now 28 but ever since
he was like six he was trained to be at
the front door when i got home with a
glass of champagne at quarter past 10.
what do you do what's your christmas
ritual pete
i'll i'll be i'll be drinking champagne
but i've i've got a day off like you
i've always worked christmas uh for the
last 50 years and uh when we've done
panto i've always had the day off no no
you haven't oh stop it
stop it in fact i will tell you very
quickly
i did that wonderful pantomime with
cilla black when she came out of
retirement she stood on the stage she
had the body she went how shall i kill
him and somebody shouted sing to him
i love that how are you before i let you
go guys um what is christmas going to
mean to you
this year given that you know it's very
different to last year but we still have
to be careful don't we uh yasmin to you
first of all
yeah i think we're still
going very slowly on this
um because of the number of infections
and
the story seems to be changing every day
but we are a little bit freer this year
which must make a lot of i know it has
made millions of people really happy
uh but but you know
one of the messages is don't go
overboard keep it small keep it sweet
yeah exactly that with a glass of sherry
what about you babe
uh no i'm just i'm going to take it easy
i'm going to see my friends by the way
kay i've got to tell you carol
vordeman's birthdays today and she's
watching right now i'm chuffed to death
so i shall drink her health as well
there we go yeah she's exactly a week
younger than me carol i think i think
yeah and we're not saying how old we are
carol are we but um
but what i will say is we're both
younger than madonna it's good to see
both of you merry christmas thank you so
much for joining
let's show off
it's good to see you thanks a lot thank
you and a very very happy christmas
carol it's always great to see you um on
the telly hopefully we'll see you soon
maybe come and have a chat to us um
tomorrow morning on the telly box i will
be here as i said uh from six o'clock in
the morning coming up in the next hour
though we're going to be talking in more
detail about the latest on omicron there
is some cautious optimism from the
government this morning so the very
latest on that and if you've got
pictures of babies in christmas outfits
we're sharing them on the telly this
morning at cave early send them to me
[Music]
you